okay let's hook agents of shield what's
been your highlights for the season each
again god I just feel like so much has
happened in this season and probably the
highlight for me was when I was given
the planet episode just to have just to
have the challenge of that was the
highlight for me as well because I got a
whole episode off everyone left me the
other thing I went back home that way
yeah I mean you got two weeks that's
that was like the most challenging thing
I've ever done and I just really enjoyed
it but I did miss I there's something
about being in in an insoluble of a
sudden when you're watching you sort of
Billy no-mates
so but so but it was really good to do
it but I was glad to get back with the
others after Elizabeth was in the room
all in 20 when you came out on stage for
the first panel that's San Diego oh my
cooks shock on your faces you saw them
that room was just insane obviously you
would have been asked or being told by
Marvel that it would have changed their
life yeah I mean what has the show done
in terms of your expectations I mean
above and beyond honestly none of us
knew what was gonna hit us we got sat
down before we shot the pilot I think
and just got plunked a big pile of comic
books in front of each of us and Jeph
Loeb for a marble set us down and said
your life's about to change and you know
just look after each other basically and
we really have taken that with us and I
think that for me has been the most
wonderful and surprising thing about the
show really is that we're a family and
Clark Gregg is the head of it well I
mean fingers imama head oh and trust me
- like babysit but Clark has kept a
really tight ship and you know he's set
from the outset that had to be we had to
talk to each other when we had to look
after each other and if anybody had any
issues or triples or whatever like we'd
come to each other and I mean I go to
him for advice most days so which I'm
sure he's regretting now one o'clock in
the morning hey steam and but he really
has just made it a family
which is just I mean it makes it great
to go to work and I'm oh and Jed and
Jeff are the showrunners really set the
tone as well and so between them and
Clark they they kind of they run a good
ship keep everybody happy like someone's
kidnapped one of your siblings they've
gone up and got married and they've gone
to university and kind of you know find
the nest yeah yeah it's all just part of
life and you know saying well no it's
just gonna say you know when you sign up
for something that maybe not everyone's
gonna make it till the end or but it it
comes as such a shock every time and we
only find out to the last minute because
that's the way it has to be so it is
like sort of suddenly you lose a limb
almost yeah oh gosh yeah we get script
to script page to page sometimes as
you're filming it like this actually
happens now just well the finale
how long did you find out that was
actually all the events of the closure
of the scene I mean what was the
timeframe was it literally days oh yeah
week the week before if you're lucky to
find out what's happening in the next
episode but if you kind of like get in
with certain people on set there was
like I think it was our last of mine and
bobbies last episode where they just got
like the breakdown for it like you know
the heads of departments but we had no
idea what was happening and I went up to
the first ad and said I think this they
they just got the script but we wouldn't
have seen it's like another way you can
I was like I was like if you seen a
script and he was like yeah yeah if
you're not like yeah yeah that's good
isn't it he's going yeah yeah oh you see
I was like yeah what what's your
favorite bit and he just told me well it
sounds like yes phase three of the
cinematic universe in play now are you
hoping that they don't start crossing
over the TV series a bit more in the
run-up to
I mean that'd be great we just go where
they tell us to i think logistically
it's just so hard we film for ten months
out of the year and this non just crazy
really long hours and you know we pack a
lot in so I think logistically it's kind
of a nightmare but you know we'd be up
for it
those films take like best part two
years to make so trying to get everybody
crossed over it's really rude yeah any
of the films you mean any of the films
ever made
well I'd like to like be in the lab with
the Hulk or something I'd like to be in
the Fitzsimmons film where it's like a
rom-com about them getting married you
could be like the love triangle is
bring a buttons oh well I mean the thing
is Ian and I get on really well and
we're really good friends but if you've
ever tried to kiss a friend I mean
they're so awkward those scenes are just
awkward and as soon as you sort of get
out of the way it's fine and then it's
fine but I mean we did have so many
conversations so it's like hey dude this
is weird isn't it yeah yeah it's weird
okay good fine as long as we both feel
weird we were just gonna say friends not
together you won't be together you wrote
me together okay fine and if you are
together nobody will know okay fine and
then you read it you go oh I guess
everyone's good but I mean I love them
as characters and I I loved that they
got together so I was happy about that
as you know and outside of it then when
you come to film it you know those
things are kind of weird like he knows
my boyfriend and just gonna kiss your
girlfriend tomorrow nope but I'm happy
I'm happy that they got together and I
hope that they can stay happy I mean as
agents of shield nothing really stays
good for very long so we'll see
highlight the days when we're just all
in yeah last episode of seasons is or
last episode for Christmas only fun like
Christmas that the caterers are do like
a huge spread and the department season
2 is really fun bags every one came down
to say yeah right in the seat was my
birthday yeah and you realize how many
people work on the show and I was like
the craft services like if I was
homeless in LA I mean yeah definitely
um I'm just really proud of her really
and kind of a strange way I think that
she's you know her and Fitz needed to
separate to get to know who they were
and them glad that they're back together
again but they're sort of back together
now more as individuals that have chosen
to be in a relationship rather than
needing each other and kind of grasping
hold of each other and you know she's
got a bit more feisty she can look after
herself she survived she's not by any
means an amazing fighter which I'm quite
grateful for because it means I don't
have to be um but I'm just yeah I'm
proud of her and I think that she's
she's also had a kind of a dodgy
relationship with Inhumans and you know
now she's
and of coming around to the fact that it
isn't always so black and white but I
think she will always go on the side of
science which you know gets her into
some tricky spots with her friends who
happen to be in humans there's been a
lot of discussion about the strength of
the presence of women particularly in
the MCU and in general how far do you
think the show ages films go on to
address that and how do you feel about
that in a wider sense what's great about
our show I think or one of the things is
that it just never mentioned it this
agent may is a brilliant agent the best
agent the most amazing Esso and happens
to be a woman it's never kind of put out
there that this is what we're doing and
that to me is the best form of feminism
you know that it's equal and it's not
kind of a big deal and it's something
that I think we're all really proud of
that we show not just that women can be
strong but that gay people can be strong
as it doesn't matter what race you are
or what your background is or you know
your nationality or that we're just you
know you're you're judged on your merit
and that's the most important thing so I
think that we have a really diverse show
and we have a diverse crew and we're
really we're really proud of that and I
think the best thing is that it just
works like I think yeah you're right it
doesn't feel like it's kind of imposed
on I just don't believe I don't believe
any anything that comes that feel like I
hope that it gets put somewhere else but
what a strong most wrong theories and
what an amazing lead and I think that
she she did amazing and you know maybe
there'll be an agent Carter movie I
always think this son comes Barry C
theory going on then it didn't get
picked up cuz actually they're making a
movie but that's not official I don't
know
one of the answer is pretty physics I'm
not just talking about the kissing
scenes how much of that do you really
want to do yourself and how much are you
okay with a stunt double doing and does
it happen often I'm completely happy was
done levels there there's some people
which are quite like Adrienne is like
she wants to do everything sometimes I'm
like you can't do she wants to do
everything I'm quite happy to let them
at the end of day you want the final
product to look it hello you will not
the final product to look as good as
possible so I'm I'm happy to get there
whatever way we have to really yeah
you're ready to put your hand up and say
I'm not yeah I like getting my hands
dirty I like um you know if there's a
running say no you know oh you know
sometimes skipping well it depends on
how vigorous this yes you do much
training for your running yeah yeah I
think she gets every day because he had
to run slow-mo in something like they
were doing in slow-mo so I'd like
Baywatch style yeah yeah so I got sent
with this like guy trains all these
athletes so that I didn't look like a
[ __ ] when I was running with my lips
flowmotion like but I did feel like like
a bit of an idiot like going right see
no braking look I I didn't really know
anything about inhumans to be perfectly
honest when when I was cast I wasn't
even sure that my character wasn't human
so was it was a very fast education for
me but I quickly discovered that there's
a very rich history in the comics and
yeah I don't know I guess it
it's a really cool thing to kind of be
one of the first representatives of that
and to you know introduce people who
haven't read the comics or who aren't
familiar with within humans to say hey
these are kind of similar to x-men but
not really that would be pretty cool but
uh yeah you know what was your thoughts
when Kevin Feige was on that segment
announcing Inhumans was in very big
letters up on the screen what was your
first thoughts very exciting obviously
and yeah there's you know I think
there's a small part of you that's like
oh my god maybe I could be a part of it
and then there's the logical part of
your brain that says shut up you idiot
but you are a part of it though we can
do as a TV show is say like how other
people feel about Inhumans and the
difficulties and the struggles and stuff
and you can get to know you know we've
got to know you over hours and hours of
seeing your eyes so that's cool that
regardless of what happens like you know
you're the foundation of that movie
babes
you